depuis 2010 est l arrivée du mouvement
mis tous la société est en pleine
transition et le questionnement autour
de la place de la femme dans la société
fait l'objet de nombreux débats on est
tous d'accord sur le fait que c'est une
révolution des femmes comment créer une
société dans laquelle chacun se sent
respecté jugé équitablement malgré les
sexes une question difficile à laquelle
certains répondent en changeant les
symboles et les représentations
c'est ce que pense visiblement indie
mailing une jeune néerlandaise de 23 ans
qui a décidé de s'attaquer à nos
célèbres jeux de cartes si vous ne
trouvez rien de choquant dans ces jeux
indie ne partage pas votre avis en effet
pour elle les figures de rois dames et
valais ont des marqueurs de domination
masculine et raciale dans ce jeu plus
inclusif
elle a donc remplacé ses figures par des
barres d'or des pièces d'argent et des
d'icônes de boucliers en bronze
une manière de nos discriminer personnes
une petite production qui s'est déjà
écoulé à 1500 exemplaires alors les jeux
de cartes sont-ils sexisme alors dans le
thème d'avant franchement nous fait ch
et pourquoi pas c'est vrai nom mais elle
a fait parler mais qui sait que cette
histoire sont fous non non on s'en fout
pas regarder gilbert et ça fait du bien
qui reviennent c'est éminemment sexistes
et c'est révoltant
regardez ce n'est pas que sexy ce qu'est
ce que c'est que cette domination d'un
roi sur une dame vous rendez les enfants
tout leur visionnage par exemple un bras
de fer avec n'importe quel jour
commettent pas n'importe lequel s'était
dit pas comme une sorte de mépris d'
insulte à mon intégrité de femmes mais
quelle horreur six élus rebelles et
d'autre part c'est raciste je vous en
avais regardées m'a regardé ils sont
tous blancs dans les jeux car tout ce
blanc n'y a pas de diversité dans les
jeux de cartes revenir quoi que les
hommes sont supérieurs aux femmes et
quatre des blancs sur terre et je vois
l'action était ils disent mais là c'est
quelqu'un qui nous vient directement du
raid
mais en mission commando ici c'est
insupportable faut arrêter de voir du
sexisme partout en plus elle choisit
très mal son exemple parce qu'il ya des
jeux de cartes ou toutes les cartes ont
la même valeur et puis une âme aux
échecs pardon c'est la dame le pion le
plus fort les pions il ya des pions
blancs et des points noirs et donc ça
n'a rien à voir il fait comme dit gérald
c'est la constitution un champion
d'échecs je peux vous dire je ne
confirme pas non mais je suis c'est un
fait regrettable faut arrêter tout
vouloir faire disparaître comme ça c'est
l'échec c'est le roi qu'il faut protéger
oui c'est ça oui c'est pénible
franchement c'est long on peut très bien
avoir une prise de positions féministes
centre et à chaque fois des tendances
loufoque insupportable pourquoi toujours
trouvé des symboles d'opposition c'est
lourd c'est pas comme ça en enlevant des
vallées des rois qu'on va lutter contre
l'inégalité des sexes et vous savez ce
qu'ils ont fait aussi les pièces inquiet
ce qu'avec des femmes non bah oui au les
cons oui parce qu'il y avait moins de
fans dans le qui est ce que d'hommes
exactement et moi je me rappelle parce
que quand on prenait vous êtes qui est
ce qu'on doit trouver le personnage
à chaque fois qu'on avait une femme on
se disait ah c'est sûr on va être
trouvée directes et maria ce qu'un à moi
exactement c'est maria ou cédric parce
qu'avec six femmes dans le piège et des
comptes est révolté je pense exactement
comme action john on va vraiment on veut
vraiment j'ai pas est ce qu'est ce
qu'elles veulent à monde android où il
ya plus ni ni ni ni sommes parfaitement
je trouve ça terrible effectivement
comme dit géraldine y donner des trucs
où les hommes sont plus forts que nous
il ya des trucs on est plus forts pas
beaucoup trop crée l'émulation des sexes
est en effet pour s'admettre s'expliquer
et se parlait qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc où plus personne ne va plus rien
osé dire ni faire et vous avez vu
d'ailleurs les femmes ont moins
d'accidents que les hommes par exemple
voiture bien c'est oui c'est un sondage
qui est sorti delphine y perdre
tellement d'énergie là ces gens là tout
contredire tout ce qui a été mis en
place la même chose pour walt disney il
contredisait walt disney et contredisent
les jeux de cartes
ils sont en train de tout remettre quant
à elle sur le tapis pour tous contredire
je trouve que c'est spécial et nicolas
aumagy perdu là il ne pas comprendre à
ce rapport ah non mais ratera je suis
complètement perdu et j'ai l'impression
que c'est une grosse plaisanterie c'est
pas possible non loin avec shenzhou
maintenant c'est un truc mais c'est pas
parce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs
regardent et 87
on arrête le débat c'est bien que vous
soyez revenue mais là franchement c'est
des minoritaires c'est bon d'être
extrêmement minoritaire sans c'est un
beau score pour moi